[Music]
before july 2019
nobody had ever heard of dream get him
george yeah the ton's a table dream yeah
dream come on but in just a year and a
half
he went from an absolute nobody to one
of the biggest names on youtube
with 15 million subscribers back when i
was growing really fast there was a
youtube bot that used to tweet out
all the fastest growing youtubers on the
entire platform and i was number one
like five days in a row
that kind of massive sudden success
would change
anyone's life but for dream not all
those changes were positive
i find it incredibly hard to believe
that dream was cheap
but man i don't know how you dispute
this [ __ ]
dream's incredible rise to fame was
unprecedented
but it didn't come without controversy
or mistakes
it's the story of a kid who set out to
reach the top but
wasn't totally ready for what he found
there
dream grew up wanting to be a youtuber
like many people his age
he wanted to be just like his favorite
youtube stars a career older generations
couldn't even imagine my entire life
i've always wanted to be a youtuber i
used to do vlogs when i was a kid
i ran a sports related channel i ran a
politics related channel
i ran a lot of different channels after
trying and failing to get those concepts
off the ground
dream turned to minecraft
[Music]
and the pig just blew up my house his
channel was clearly trying to entertain
but
he also knew what set off the minecraft
community one of my strategies when i
was starting youtube was to use reddit
to my advantage because any post can go
viral on reddit even if you have no
followers or anything but dream's early
success was still tied to the titans of
youtube he looked up to as a kid
and that came with controversy this is
the team
that found pewdiepie's minecraft world
seed yes
that randomly generated number that had
over 18 quintillion possibilities
this is the team that found that number
just by watching pewdiepie dream managed
to figure out the worlds he had used by
pewdiepie for his minecraft playthrough
meaning that
dream had access to pewdiepie's world
and that made pewds fans worry that his
playthrough might get spoiled as a
result
this really sucks because he posted this
video after we had already released the
seed
pewdiepie seemed to be worried about
spoilers and so he was going to wait now
i do want to say first things first i'm
sorry pewdiepie
if you had posted this just a couple
hours earlier you would have had your
wish
but dream continued to put out videos
that targeted minecraft players
ignoring anyone he pissed off along the
way minecraft was blowing up
on youtube and dream was getting bigger
and bigger by releasing content that put
a new spin on the old game
this video we coded it ourselves so that
random items drop when you break a block
but there's a couple twists from the
norm one it's actually completely random
so some items may be removed from the
game whereas some items may be in the
game
multiple times two the number of items
the block drops is random so it can drop
one or it can drop one million and crash
our games
it seemed like dream had perfectly set
himself up for youtube stardom
he had a nose for great video ideas a
likable personality
and of course the mysterious appeal of a
masked man
in late 2019 a couple of big video hits
with innovative gimmicks gave dream a
bump in popularity
and he hit a million subscribers by the
end of the year and over the course of
2020
dreams youtube channel managed to become
even more popular
please just leave me alone why would we
leave you alone silly boy
oh it's good and this enderman's on me
why the enemies hate me
series like minecraft manhunt did a lot
to popularize dream as not only
entertaining but also
a legitimately good minecraft player
this video is an
absolutely new and unique challenge i'm
gonna try and beat minecraft before my
friend
kills me once if i die the video is over
and i lose my friend gets a compass to
track me and can respawn
infinitely the outplays big brain
moments and banter between dream and his
companions
pushed his popularity to a whole new
level
get him get him george yeah the tons of
table drinks yeah
dream come on
no no oh the skeleton
yes get on the skeleton get him oh now
oh my god dreams rise was literally
unprecedented
in the span of a year he went from an
absolute nobody to one of the biggest
content creators in gaming
and people didn't even know what he
looked like i actually first started
planning to be a youtuber probably in
january 2019
but i didn't upload my first video until
july 2019. i actually have this funny
screenshot of me telling my friend
lakota that i planned it all out and
that i was gonna be a big youtuber and
that was in
february 2019 about four months before i
posted my first video
it's been super crazy and i i remember
back when i was growing really fast
there was a youtube bot that used to
tweet out
all the fastest growing youtubers on the
entire platform and i was number one
like five days in a row and i thought
that was
super insane dream success morphed into
something even bigger
most notably the dream smp or survival
multiplayer minecraft server
where he and his friends including the
dream team wove narratives through role
play
countless storylines were chronicled by
dreams fans and dream himself even
started rubbing shoulders with
celebrities
like lil nazex who toured the server oh
that's the castle
it's eric's castle
by december 2020 dream had gone from 1
million subscribers
to 15 million he was collaborating with
massive names like corpse husband and mr
beast and was an important influencer
with his own merch and a legion of fans
there was just one problem a couple
months earlier
dream made a mistake that threatened to
destroy his entire
youtube empire in 2020 dreams started
speedrunning a specific minecraft
category called any percent random seed
glitchless which is basically a race to
kill the ender dragon in a randomly
seated world
and in october dreams submitted a time
for that category that made him the
sixth fastest player in the world
oh my god
[Applause]
but soon after the mods at speedrun.com
decided to look a little deeper
into dreams times see in order to
complete minecraft you have to get these
rare items called ender pearls to let
you access the area where you can fight
the ender dragon
but dream was able to get these items a
lot more consistently than mere luck
should have allowed
see dream was getting pearl drops at an
astronomically high rate
a rate that led youtubers like shell guy
and video game dunky
to publish videos accusing dream of
cheating across recent speed runs he had
streamed on twitch
a speedrun.com mod named geosquare
eventually revealed the mod team's
findings
dream's luck wasn't just improbable it
was basically
impossible now this really isn't looking
too good for dream
biasing in favor of him giving very
favorable circumstances and assuming the
best
the odds for all this happening is still
around 1 in 678 trillion
as a result of that investigation
dream's record was taken off the
leaderboards
so i understood absolutely nothing when
it came to the game but the math behind
that is so [ __ ] wild
i find it incredibly hard to believe
that dream would cheat
especially in what's not even a world
record run
but man i don't know how you dispute
this [ __ ]
i can tell you guys immediately just
like dude this is so
lucky it makes no sense but despite
denying that he cheated
dream's internet fame was creating more
complications
he was doxed when someone used photos of
his home to track down his address and
release it to the public
another youtuber john swan impersonated
him sending racist messages to people
and as a now massive celebrity dream's
tweets messages and even his attitude
were constantly scrutinized
going either way you know consent is a
whole thing
[Applause]
fan base started causing problems going
after anyone who dared to criticize
their hero
by may 2020 dream had finally had enough
the constant barrage of hate from all
sides got to him and
he came clean dream admitted that his
speed run wasn't legit
saying that he discovered evidence that
item probabilities had been modified in
his speed run by server-side add-ons
that he claimed he didn't know about
he also apologized for his strong
reactions to the initial claims that he
cheated
now in admitting he cheated he also
apologized but
it wasn't really an apology and the
response from those who aren't
die hard dream fans has been one
giant scoff i had considered at the time
that this potentially could have been a
problem
but brushed it off because one server
side and client-side are completely
different
and as far as i was aware nothing had
been done client-side
two as far as i knew it was just
basically a chat mod
so far and three i was 99
sure that i didn't even have the
recording mod on which was backed up by
the fabric api
logs saying that only the fabric api was
loaded
end quote the cheating question was
finally answered
but it raised a few others why did dream
take so
long to admit he cheated had he really
never considered how he got that lucky
and where did this leave his future and
fandom like if he had just come out and
been straight with
everyone and said something like you
know what i [ __ ] up i did cheat
i apologize my bad this whole situation
would have been a non-starter in my
opinion
when you finish minecraft there's a
sequence to plays before you see the
credits
it's a cryptic message part short story
part psychedelic stream of consciousness
it's directed at the player and at the
end it offers
hope for a new beginning
[Music]
[Applause]
dream clearly made mistakes but he also
brought something new and fresh to
minecraft
a scene with a deep history and a keen
sense of wonder
it's impossible to predict what he'll do
in the future so far the controversies
haven't had a substantial
impact on his popularity but one thing
seems clear
in 2021 there is a legion of fans hoping
that dream will begin
a new dream and that this time he'll
dream
better thanks for watching if you want
more content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite size
videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our instagram
twitter and facebook pages you